cuando era niño Jefferson o shody soñaba
con ser un gran médico en Nigeria sin
embargo pronto se irá de lagos este
médico general está cansado de hacer
malabares con todas las carencias
posibles e imaginables como millones de
nigerianos Jefferson ya no quiere fingir
que todo va bien prefiere darse por
vencido y emigrar al Reino Unido yo como
médico empiezo mi turno en el hospital a
las 8 de la mañana pero sé que necesito
dinero o gasolina entonces tengo que
hacer fila en el cajero o en la estación
de servicio durante ese tiempo el
paciente me va a estar esperando aquí
las urgencias van a llegar aquí la gente
se puede morir no es así en otros países
la gente no se pelea en el cajero en el
Reino Unido o en Canadá acá sí la OMS
recomienda que haya un médico por cada
600 pacientes en Nigeria la proporción
es de uno por cada 9000 según la
asociación Nacional de médicos de los
80.000 médicos
registrados en Nigeria solo 24.000 están
ejerciendo Jefferson trabaja 96 horas a
la semana en promedio
[Aplausos]
en realidad es terrible hemos intentado
convencer al gobierno de que cuide a los
médicos para que los médicos puedan
cuidar al pueblo nigeriano no es difícil
de entender
pero en la época en que vivimos el nivel
de vida de los médicos es terrible tengo
mucho miedo por Nigeria
significa correr huir o escapar y se ha
convertido en el objetivo de una parte
de la clase media nigeriana
franken de esta fuga de cerebros en su
estudio de arquitectura por este motivo
está Franco nigeriana contrató a
arquitectos recién egresados y sabe que
después de uno o dos años de experiencia
en su empresa todos sus nuevos empleados
recibirán ofertas de trabajo en el
extranjero ya habíamos desarrollado una
rutina Ya teníamos nuestro sistema y
sobre todo se había realizado una
capacitación interna y ahora tenemos que
hacernos a la idea de que todos los
esfuerzos que hagamos para capacitarlos
son a corto plazo
salaco Busca obtener una visa de
estudiante para poder irse de Nigeria
pero para esta mujer de 40 años los
trámites son complejos porque quiere
emigrar con sus dos hijos y su marido
por tanto debe reunir más de 20.000
euros para cubrir todos los gastos gemis
y salaco ASUME esta pesada carga para
cambiar de vida
siento que valdrá la pena porque estoy
segura que después de cinco años Seré
una mejor persona habría obtenido las
cualificaciones que siempre quise habré
trabajado en el campo de mi elección
mis hijos habrán recibido la educación
de calidad que quiero que tengan
y trabaja aquí en hoyo y administra esta
tienda el deterioro de la seguridad en
su ciudad y en todo el país es una
fuente de preocupación para esta
comerciante Jamie si quiere vivir en el
extranjero porque Nigeria los
comerciantes son blanco de ataques y
secuestros para elegir un rescate
solo quiero un ambiente sano Quiero una
vida sana sencilla en la que pueda tener
una buena vida y pueda dormir con los
dos ojos bien cerrados
migrar o no migrar cofo y a quien culé o
lonluye decidieron criar a sus hijos en
Nigeria a veces se replantean su
decisión Cuando se enteran de que algún
familiar se marchó definitivamente al
extranjero después de estudiar y vivir
con sus padres en Estados Unidos a quien
culé decidió regresar a lagos en 2004 se
asoció con unos amigos para fundar un
sello discográfico volver a casa es muy
fácil para mí no fue una decisión muy
difícil Sí hay muchas cosas que
extrañamos aquí aún no estamos tan
desarrollados como en Estados Unidos
pero al mismo tiempo Nigeria tiene su
propio Encanto su propia riqueza sus
propios valores sus propias
oportunidades que quizás no existan en
ninguna otra parte aquí trabaja Cinco
noches a la semana como Dj o lo abrus
mezcla para la jetset nigeriana en los
clubes más populares de lagos y mientras
lo haces se olvida de todos los
problemas de la vida en Nigeria
inseguridad cortes de Electricidad
desigualdades sociales a quien julé no
planea marcharse a corto plazo Aunque
cuando sus hijos crezcan quiere poder
ofrecerles otras opciones dentro de 20
años mis hijos y yo Tendremos una casa
aquí pero seguramente pasaremos la mayor
parte del tiempo fuera del país para ese
entonces quiero que vivan cosas
diferentes les daré una base sólida en
Nigeria Pero antes de eso quiero
mostrarles el mundo la idea de quedarse
en Nigeria primera potencia económica de
África por ahora no atrae a gran parte
de su población en 2022 se entregaron
1,9 millones de nuevos pasaportes casi
el doble que en 2021 con un millón según
las cifras publicadas por el servicio de
inmi ción nigeriano y entre los
solicitantes la mayoría son jóvenes